We're going to be talking about
marijuana this week.
I'll give you guys just a sec to roll a
joint,
pack a bowl or put fresh water in the
bond.
Of course,
those are just a couple of the old
school ways of getting stone these days.
It also includes vaping,
waxes,
edibles and oils.
I should tell you,
I've tried all of them a couple times
each to cure this darn glaucoma.
I diagnosed myself with back in high
school.
I still have been being cured,
but there is always hope before we get
into a big discussion about marijuana,
meaning legalization,
health benefits,
recreational use,
and more.
It's only fair if I tell you guys a bit
about my history with weed.
After smoking,
my first joint during Sophomore Year of
college for a couple of years,
I was probably what most would consider
a pothead.
I'd get stoned and watch TV,
right,
or go grocery shopping and gathering all
the best snacks I could get ahold of.
I should note I never got into a fight,
robbed a bank or murdered anyone while
smoking weed.
After College.
I smoke now and again,
usually while just hanging out with
friends,
despite the marijuana raging through our
systems,
we also seem to never get into a fight.
Rob a bank or murder anyone since moving
to la where medicinal marijuana is
legal,
at least on the state level.
I got my med card and I smoke every
couple weeks.
Usually I enjoy a nice bowl at the end
of a long day when I just want to veg
out and watch Seinfeld or the simpsons
and to this day I haven't gotten into a
fight,
robbed a bank or murdered anyone while
smoking weed.
When it comes to marijuana,
I'm a libertarian through and through
what I do with my own body in my own
house is nobody else's business,
much less the government.
As long as I'm not doing harm to another
person,
then I have the right to do as I wish.
As a citizen.
This is a place where libertarianism
makes absolute sense to me.
We don't even have to get into the
health benefits or the dangers of other
currently legal drugs.
The liberal argument for weed is pretty
good too,
which basically is.
It's not doing any real damage,
so you should be able to smoke it.
Plus we're putting too many people in
jail for partaking in a drug that
generally doesn't lead to criminal
behavior.
This is a case where libertarians and
classical liberals take on something
really lines up.
On the other hand,
conservatives in the US have generally
been against marijuana.
They call it a gateway drug,
which is pretty much like calling
Gerber's a gateway.
Food conservatives have scared people
into thinking that marijuana will make
you a criminal or degenerate and they
don't mind wasting your taxpayer money,
locking up people for a personal choice
that they do with their own bodies.
There are some conservatives who even
now with all we know about the multiple
benefits of marijuana are still against
legalizing even at a medicinal level.
Ironically,
it's conservatives who also preach about
small government.
Yet they seem to want to regulate what
you do in the privacy of your own home,
while at the same time wasting taxpayer
dollars,
which they say they want to save on
trumped up criminal charges.
Of course,
none of these examples are perfect,
which is why ran Paul Libertarian still
hasn't fully come around on the
marijuana issue and Hillary Clinton,
a Democrat hasn't either.
Meanwhile,
the Republican candidates are all
against it in one form or another,
despite the fact that the only tolerable
way to watch a republican debate is
milestone.
The one candidate who I do think
understands the issue is Bernie Sanders,
who wants to decriminalize marijuana at
the federal level.
Ironically,
in this incidence,
it's the big government guy who is
making the government smaller by getting
them out of your private life and not
putting you in jail for having a good
time.
If you are sick with cancer or with
Parkinson's,
why should the government or any other
human being be able to stop you from
doing anything that would alleviate your
pain and suffering?
If you get caught with marijuana,
should you have your life ruined by
being thrown in a federal jail?
If you get really high and watched the
wizard of Oz with dark side of the moon,
playing in the background doesn't really
sync up.
These are just some of the important
questions that talking about weed brings
up.
My guest this week is Angel Tieger
Angeles,
part of the Los Angeles medical cannabis
taskforce and owns her own edibles
company,
Ruby Doobie.
She got involved with marijuana after
Western medicine,
failed to help her with her debilitating
migraines.
Angel now speaks about the medicinal
benefits of marijuana,
the ongoing quest for legalization and
removing the stigma attached to the
conversation.
Some of you have probably heard me tell
the story of how in 1997 I went to see
the movie Air Force One after eating
some pot brownies with a couple of
friends.
The movie was sold out,
so we walked into another movie called
contact,
which I had never heard of.
Remember that incredibly mindblowing,
extended panorama of the universe that
opens the movie.
Well,
it may sound Corny,
but my world actually felt bigger.
After seeing that movie stoned,
I ended up reading many of the books by
Carl Sagan,
who is the author of contact and
brilliant scientists.
After seeing that movie,
that stoned moment opened up something
in me that got me interested in many of
the ideas that I talk about today.
Maybe it would have happened without the
weed,
but it sure didn't hurt.
That also reminds me,
I'd love to tell you about the week I
spent in the red light district in
Amsterdam a couple of years ago.
I just can't remember any of it.
Angel Tieger is a speaker and activist
and an entrepreneur.
She works with the La Cannabis medical
task force and runs her own cannabis
edibles company known as Ruby Doobie and
we've got a lot of Ruby doobie goodies
in front of us right now.
Angel,
thanks for.
Thanks for joining me.
Thank you for inviting me.
Dave.
Yeah.
I'm very excited to talk to you because
I've wanted to do something a little
more in depth on pot for a long time.
And uh,
and you brought pot cookies and
brownies.
Let's get into this stuff first and then
we'll talk about the history and
legalization.
What,
what are we going
in front of some of the things that I
make.
I'm sweet dreams Brownie.
It's a dusted with a little bit of sea
salt on top.
It's about 57 milligrams here.
Okay.
Fifty seven milligrams of thc.
What does that mean?
So you,
you eat that.
How do you feel after?
Well,
I personally would not eat a whole
Brownie.
I would have half and that's plenty for
me,
but it really depends on your metabolism
and your,
your,
uh,
how experienced you are and it can
differ on things depending on the day
and on how much you've eaten that day.
But um,
and,
and dosage,
dosage guidelines.
Very,
you know,
I've seen a recommended dosages that
between five and 15 milligrams for
people or some who want between 20 and
and this is all sort of unchartered
territory for a lot of people because
for a long time,
you know,
I,
I think I said once I,
the show,
when I got my weed card I went in there
and I said,
you know,
they showed me wax.
They showed me oil.
They showed me edibles and I said,
well,
do you have any just weed,
you know,
green buds,
like old fashioned weed.
And that made me feel like,
oh,
like,
that guy wants to smoke weed,
but this is sort of the new thing,
right?
Well,
I mean,
you,
I think not as many people are familiar
with edibles,
but it's been around and um,
it's a great way to make use of the
whole plant because really what,
when you smoke,
you're smoking the flowers,
the buds,
but you still have all of the leaves and
the trim and the small buds and all of
that has you active ingredients in it
too.
And that's primarily what I use to make
my goodies.
And here's the peanut butter Brownie.
A ginger cookie crew is very excited by
the way.
Oh,
I'm happy a ginger cookies and cream
cookies and chocolate chip cookies.
And I make cakes and other things
to lemon bars.
So you make all this stuff and this is
for people that may want the medicinal
benefits.
This is for people that may want the
recreational benefits.
A,
it doesn't matter to you,
right?
Like you're selling it for then and
yeah,
it's nice if someone could alleviate
some pain.
Well,
I worked with the dispensary's,
I worked with a handful of dispensaries
in,
in my area.
Um,
so I,
I'm,
I'm a member that's,
that's providing edibles for my fellow
members.
Sure.
And um,
you know,
you can't really,
you can't in California,
you still have to get a doctor's
recommendations even go to those
dispensary's so it isn't tried and it's
tough to make the distinction between
what's recreate for,
in my mind,
it's,
it's tough to distinguish between a
recreational and medicinal because if
it's,
if you're using it to relax at the end
of the day and um,
to,
to distress.
Yeah.
Um,
all right,
so let's get a little bit into your
story and then we'll talk about business
and legalization and all that shit.
So you got into,
we'd basically,
I think you were smoking it
recreationally,
but the reason you really got into this
was because you were having migraines
and pretty much the western medicine
that you were trying
wasn't working,
right?
Yes,
but I,
I think there were two forces that kind
of a both intersected in and drove me
into cannabis and definitely my
migraines.
Um,
I,
I've had migraines for many,
many years and about 10 years ago they
started getting a lot worse and more
frequent and I was,
I'm trying all kinds of different
medications.
I had,
um,
steroids injected into my nap to try to
get rid of them.
I had some prescriptions that were so
strong that they require the triplicate
prescription and nothing helped me.
I mean a,
lots of times that the drugs would
irritate my stomach so much that I would
feel worse sometimes they would just
knock me out and that's how I survived
my migraines.
And cannabis is really what allowed me
to,
to continue living and manage them
without having to check out for weeks at
a time or days at a time.
Um,
so that definitely treating my migraines
was one for us.
And also a desire to simplify my life.
You know,
I,
um,
I was working at the x prize foundation.
I was a chief of staff there and um,
you know,
very rewarding,
challenging position.
Um,
but I just felt that there was something
missing.
You know,
I,
I wasn't spending very much time with my
son who was two years old at the time,
uh,
I would have to travel a lot and um,
I just wanted to create a change in my
life where I would,
uh,
not be so dependent on,
on a check,
a grow,
grow my own food and Cook my own meals
and,
and rather than pay someone to do this
and that,
I wanted to do those things I wanted to
be the one with,
with my family.
Right.
So that's really interesting.
So it wasn't just I want to get stoned
and had the good time.
You got into the edible garden thing,
which was nice.
You were growing weed but you were also
growing stuff to actually eat and to eat
your child.
We were growing and at one point we were
going enough food in our garden that it
was too much for us to even eat.
I mean,
neighbors would come and we encouraged
our neighbors to come and,
um,
tomatoes,
artichokes,
peppers,
eggplants,
a,
uh,
collared Greens,
Shard Kale.
I mean,
we still have,
you know,
lemon trees,
apple trees,
a nectarines,
oranges.
It's a beautiful thing to,
to just go outside and pick your food
and you know,
you don't have to get in your car.
You can't get anything fresher than
that.
Yeah,
it's funny.
I have,
I mean,
I live in La too and you know,
I have a little outdoor space with a
little garden and even if I'm just
plucking tomatoes or something,
I find that very therapeutic.
Oh,
it is just that action of doing,
of growing something for yourself,
whether it's marijuana or a tomato or
pepper or something.
Even right there connecting with nature.
So this is all intertwined with
ultimately you going into this business.
I believe so.
I mean,
it's wanting to simplify,
wanting to be more in touch with nature,
you know,
it's,
it's so easy to get disconnected from
food and to know what food looks like
when it's actually growing.
I mean,
um,
when I,
uh,
when we first planted our garden,
it was with the help of a nonprofit
called La Green grounds and uh,
we had 50 volunteers come out and help
us plant our front yard and our parkways
and um,
I was intimidated because I had never
tried to grow food before and I didn't
know how it all worked and it's never
put my hands in the dirt and planted
anything and to watch things grow and to
be able to feed my family that way and,
and help,
you know,
feed the neighborhood.
Um,
it was an amazing experience.
And food.
Food is medicine.
You know,
cannabis is medicine.
I mean,
I really don't see much of a difference.
Right?
So you see this green thing that grows
naturally from the earth,
like all this other stuff that we eat.
You see that just sort of as an
extension of every other thing,
but the city wasn't that thrilled.
Right?
With your,
with your garden.
So here you are a person that sort
already takes life into your own hands
on your own property and the city of Los
Angeles.
What did they do?
Well,
okay.
Going back a little while.
I.
What got me inspired to plant the garden
was I watched a Ted talk by Ron Finley.
I don't know if you've heard of him,
the,
uh,
a guerrilla garden against gangster
gardener.
So the whole idea of that he presented
growing your own food is like printing
your own money.
I mean,
there was some things that just
resonated so deeply with me that
immediately after I saw the talk,
I,
I got in touch with la green grounds and
said,
I need to learn how to do this.
How,
how can I volunteer?
Um,
and,
uh,
it turns out they were actually looking
for an la resident.
I'm a to plant a garden.
Um,
and,
uh,
the timing was perfect.
So we planted,
we were selected in and that's how we
got our garden.
Um,
so yeah,
the city though,
didn't want you to do it at some point.
Right.
So Ron,
when he,
when he did his ted talk,
he had planted an edible garden a few
years before mine
and was cited and um,
went to city council and,
uh,
made the case that it doesn't make
sense.
You should allow people to grow food on
their,
on their parkways,
and the city council at that time agreed
and said that,
um,
they would work to change the laws and
fast forward two years later,
I plant,
we plant our garden and I was operating
under the assumption that it was all
good.
Right?
But the changes were in the works.
Um,
but a few months after,
um,
this w we were cited,
I'm a guy,
came to my house and kind of
aggressively said,
you know,
all of this has to come out and you have
48 hours to put it all back to the way
it was.
And,
and there's nothing to do with weed.
Just to me,
this is growing squash,
eggplants.
Yeah.
Things like that.
So,
um,
that because we had the support of a lot
of,
you know,
La Green grounds and Ron and um,
it was easy to,
to get attention drawn to the,
to the issue it had been going on for
some time.
Steve Lopez from the La Times came out
and wrote an article about our,
our garden and it,
it,
uh,
it helped bring the city council's
attention back to this issue and I'm not
long after that they did change the laws
so anyone in La can,
can,
uh,
grow fruits and vegetables on their,
on their parkway before you had to.
There was only a short list of approved
things you could grow.
And if you wanted to deviate from that,
you had to,
uh,
I think a file a request and I think it
was like $400.
Stephen asked just to ask
to use your own property,
your own yes.
And then,
you know,
you might not get the approval.
Now,
I think the way the law reads is you can
grow whatever you want except for,
um,
uh,
some,
some fruit trees are not allowed to be
on the parkway.
But it was,
it's a huge step.
Right?
Right now,
as long as you have a medical marijuana
license,
you can also grow weed.
I'm guessing you can't do that in the
front of your house though with.
I don't think I would say it would be
such a good idea.
Probably not the greatest idea.
All right,
well I don't want to get too into the
weeds on that.
No Pun intended,
but I thought it was an interesting way
to start because it shows how marijuana
and legalization and the distal uses and
all that are so tied into our legal
system and then we can get into some of
that stuff.
So.
All right,
so you have the Migraines,
you start saying,
all right,
I'm going to smoke weed to make myself
feel better.
How long did it take to figure out what
worked for you,
what actually was the right strain?
And can you talk about strains a little
bit?
You know,
I,
I know with some conditions,
um,
people look for particular strains.
Um,
uh,
you know,
I think.
Okay,
so there,
there are.
Yeah,
let's do,
let's do one on one.
When you talk about cannabis there a
cannabis,
indica and sativa,
right?
I'm sit there.
They look different physically,
like sativa plants are usually taller
and leaner,
thinner branches and a grow better in
warmer climates.
Indicas are kind of shorter and Bush
year and heartier.
Um,
besides that,
indicas are usually,
um,
they helped you relax.
You,
um,
most people will use them at night to as
a sleep aid or um,
and sativas generally will give you more
energy and let you keep more focus.
So more people will use.
Sativa is during the day because you can
still function
all my comedian friends that get stoned
on sativas and write all day.
Right?
And then,
um,
uh,
within,
okay,
so you have strains that are either
endeca or sativa or they can be a
hybrid.
Um,
and then each particular strain has its
own,
uh,
profile,
how much thc is in there,
how much cbd is in there.
So let's unpack that a little bit.
So thc is the psychoactive part.
Correct.
And CBD is,
is the medicinal part.
Is that fair to describe it?
That thc also has medicinal
properties,
but it is the psychoactive element.
CBD is,
is cannabidiol.
It's another cannabinoid.
Those aren't the only two.
I mean,
there,
there are others,
um,
and,
but CBD does seem to have most of the
medicinal value.
I mean,
it can,
it can.
Um,
it's been shown to a stop some tumor
growth.
It's um,
uh,
you know,
it's great for pain relief.
Um,
it's a,
uh,
reduces inflammation.
Um,
you know,
it's,
I have a friend that takes cbd oil for
anxiety and she told me all she does,
literally as she was a little dropper in
the morning,
she drops two drops every time.
That's it.
She doesn't have the diarrhea and
vomiting and thoughts of suicide and
restless leg syndrome and all the other
crazy things that come with all the
commercials that you see on tv for all
these other antidepressants and
antianxiety it's,
it's,
it's so gentle.
I mean,
it has so many benefits and has never
killed anyone.
Um,
you mentioned that at the top.
I've never murdered anyone,
but it's still,
boggles my mind that,
uh,
a plant,
first of all,
that has so many medicinal properties.
So besides medicine,
I mean,
what about renewable energy and uh,
you know,
paper,
I mean,
it's strong.
It's a strong fiber,
replaced so many things.
Um,
the fact that we look at it as such an
evil thing,
um,
I don't understand.
I can,
I can tell it.
It truly boggles the mind.
Yes,
yes.
Alright.
So we have a thc cbd,
uh,
and then you have the indigo and the
sativa and the hybrids of that.
Um,
so for the medicinal stuff,
let's just do that first.
Most people,
if you didn't want to get stoned but you
just wanted medicinal benefits,
that's where you would use just the cbd,
is that right?
Okay.
CBD,
yes.
You want that.
But there's been a lot of research
researched that shows that a cbd alone
is not as effective as when you mix it
with thc,
meaning that it's the whole plant that
you want to treat you with.
Not just taking one piece of it.
Um,
I think it's referred to as the
entourage effect because there's so many
elements and they all kind of worked
together.
Um,
so people who are looking for cbd are
usually looking for cbd rich strains or
in some cases,
you know,
like the,
the concentrates and things like that.
Um,
but I think for the most part you'll
find that they're more effective when,
when there is a little thc in there.
Yeah.
So when you found the right one for you
for.
Well,
first off,
how long did it take for you to find the
weed that was like,
oh,
these migraines?
Nah,
you know,
I didn't even think about weight as a
treatment for my migraines because when
I get bad migraines I would get barrier.
I'm nauseous,
dizzy.
Um,
uh,
smoking pot was the last thing I thought
would help me really.
Um,
but then I did read that it,
it helps.
And um,
for me it's,
it,
it relaxes me enough that,
I mean,
it,
it helps the nausea.
Um,
and also it helps me control the anxiety
that comes along with,
with,
um,
the onset of a migraine.
I don't know,
two things attacking you at once,
you have the Migraine,
but then knowing it's coming now you're
saying,
oh my gosh.
About that.
And try to hit both of those.
Both of those things.
Yeah.
Um.
Alright.
So then you started doing that.
It was working.
When did you say,
all right,
I could make a business out of this or I
gotta I gotTa tell people what's going
on here.
Well,
you know,
a friend of mine was baking and I was
fascinated by it and so I would um,
look up recipes and send them to me.
You should try this,
you should try that.
And he's finally,
he got to the point where you said,
you know what angel,
you should try it.
So I started experimenting and um,
that's how I got introduced to making
edibles and then I started trying them
because,
well honestly I tried a few edibles and
hated them.
You Go,
this is going back to like 2008 or
something.
I mean,
because you.
Before they had perfected.
Exactly.
I mean,
at that time he'd go to a dispensary and
you see stuff that was just in like
Ziploc bags and,
you know,
totally unappetizing to look at and
oftentimes didn't taste very good and I
mean,
I,
I found myself in those early days just
sort of like,
you know,
eating it real quick and just hoping for
the,
we're now,
it's like literally,
it's like going into a great big
Oh,
you can get any,
anything,
pizza sauces.
So
this can be anything you can think of.
Yeah.
So you started making this and it was
really for yourself and then you started
selling it.
How quickly did you realize they were
going to be some legal issues?
Even in California where it is legal?
Uh,
well,
right away,
right away.
I mean,
you know,
there's still such a problem with
perception first of all.
So,
okay.
California was the first to allow for
medical marijuana.
It's been that way for about 20 years.
But,
uh,
beyond doing that,
there really aren't any regulations
established.
So,
uh,
it's like the wild west or it has been
like that.
Um,
and there are a lot of people who want
to do the right thing,
wants to operate in a safe way,
but without guidelines,
without regulations,
you can't really do that.
And um,
you know,
there because of the perception problem,
because of the stigma problem,
because there are no clear laws.
A dispensary's are still being attacked,
closed down,
shut down.
And um,
literally,
I mean,
you're not making the dispensaries in
California,
there was a dispensary maybe five blocks
away from me that about six ago was
closed down.
It was legal within the California set
of laws,
but federally,
because it's not legal,
the feds pretty much at anytime could
come in and stop you.
Right,
right.
But I'm at risk right now and we have no
fans watching.
Sorry about that.
Yeah.
But in,
and it's not even just,
it's not that the,
I guess that is the case in some
instances that the feds do come in and
shut them down,
but even local municipalities are going
in and shutting down places because
they're using,
um,
land use codes to evict people and
threatened their landlords.
And I'm sure shadow places down.
Yeah,
so how do you operate knowing that,
that sort of out there,
it's a very precarious position to be in
as,
as a business person?
Yes.
Well,
first of all it's a business,
but for me it's primarily a passion
project.
You know,
I do this because it means a lot to me
to be in the industry and um,
to help change how help change
perspectives on it.
Um,
I,
I know that I believe that a lot of
people who are anti marijuana,
I really just a misinformed,
you know,
there's been a lot of negative
propaganda,
um,
and it's going to take some time to get
good real information out to people.
Yeah.
This is sorta like for people that are
pro marijuana even,
not even recreationally,
but even medicinally,
this is sorta the fault of you've had
the government which scared people about
marijuana,
right?
You can think of those,
just those posters in the sixties,
you know,
just like making everyone look evil,
smoking weed,
and then even the Hollywood side of
things,
Hollywood,
which is obviously very liberal and pro
drug generally,
but every movie related to Pod is just a
bunch of goofballs doing ridiculous
things.
So it makes it seem like it's going to
make you dumb or stupid or something
like that.
Yeah.
There's really nothing in between those
two places,
which is.
Well,
I guess this is,
this is between those two years,
you'd be surprised at how many of us
really fall in between.
Most people aren't at the extremes.
Me,
I can't believe it.
It's just that people are afraid to come
out and,
and rightly so because because it is
still federally illegal and,
and there is still this stigma attached
to it.
Uh,
when I was working full time and in the
corporate world,
I definitely kept,
might use a private because I didn't
want to be judged.
It's,
I didn't feel ashamed,
but I didn't want anyone to use that
information against me.
And I think that,
um,
that a lot of people fall into that
category and it's a shame because it,
it's so easy to keep those stereotypes
going of the pot head stoner,
um,
you know,
it's easy to,
to,
to dismiss the whole industry if that's
all you have in your head when you think
about it.
But there's so much more to it than
that.
Yeah.
I'm so fascinated by that because,
you know,
I've talked about,
gay people coming out,
they're not trying to push anyone else
interested in gay.
There is coming out for themselves.
Exactly.
I've talked about this related to
atheist because I get emails all the
time were atheist,
even in western societies where it's
okay to be atheist will say I'm afraid
of coming out because you might have an
effect on my job or my parents or my
cousin or something like that.
And I never thought of it really in the
context of marijuana.
But yeah,
as a professional person you didn't want
to be seen a certain way.
So how did you remove that stigma?
I mean,
did you go home to your parents and say,
I'm going to go on and do this and weed
once I decided that this was important
and this is what I wanted to do,
I definitely made a shift to being out
and I told my parents,
you know,
and this is what I'm doing.
I use cannabis for my migraines.
I use cannabis,
you know,
I,
I'm still a good mother,
you know,
a productive member of society.
I mean,
not that they questioned me.
Um,
but,
but you felt it was like sort of on you
to sell your case in a way or something.
Yes.
And it's interesting,
you know,
there's still,
even though they know what I do is,
is good.
Um,
they believed that I'm providing a good.
but there's,
you know,
they worry,
they worried they,
they,
they see how the laws are and see how
um,
you know,
there's a risk.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
So one of the laws that I simply cannot
believe is this section one thing,
right?
So this is that the federal government
basically says at this point that
marijuana has no medical benefit.
There's a jillion studies that show
that's not true.
There is a zillion examples of people
like yourself that show that that's not
true.
I've smoked weed after hurting my knee
playing basketball and fell better.
So,
you know,
most people know that this isn't true,
but this is the Obama administration
that still is backing this.
So when these dispensaries are closed
here in California,
where again,
it is legal,
this is coming from Obama who was pretty
good on weed.
So it's,
it's so complex,
isn't it?
Yes.
I,
I had hoped for more change,
uh,
you know,
I did read the other day,
who knows if this is true that Gary
Johnson predicted that Obama would we
classify or declassify it on his way out
and,
you know,
that's kind of one by the way.
Um,
so that would be amazing if he did that.
yeah,
it's,
I had Gary Johnson on the show and I
mean a libertarian,
as I was saying at the top,
a libertarian should be the most pro
we'd person there is,
this is you and your life and you're not
pushing it on kids.
You're doing something that makes you
feel bad.
Yeah.
I,
I think the problem is just this,
it's been this way for so long.
It's hard to change course,
especially when you're going pretty much
one 80,
you know,
I mean to have cannabis,
uh,
on the schedule one,
it has led to so many people suffering
needlessly,
you know,
being put in prison.
I'm having criminal records that affect
the rest of their lives.
And what's horrifying about it is that
it's,
it impacts communities of color more so
this whole war on drugs is a failure and
it,
it's been used as a way to target
certain communities.
And um,
I think just this week there was
something that came out at one of
Nixon's advisors has now admitted.
Yes.
Part of what they did related to
criminalizing certain drugs was
purposely aimed at minority communities
that you're not just picking up
exactly fact,
yes,
I read that same thing and he,
he admitted it was the hippies and,
and the African Americans that they
wanted to be able to go into those
communicate communities,
um,
arrest their leaders,
raid their homes with.
That was the goal.
Um,
and here we are,
it's,
it's still happening,
it's still happening.
Um,
and so I think we're asking people,
you know,
law enforcement to give up control of
this.
Um,
and um,
you know,
there are a lot of law enforcement that,
that believe that's for the best,
but there's still resistance because
it's the way we've operated for so many
years.
Right.
So basically if you're a business owner,
like yourself or someone at a dispensary
or you're just somebody that likes weed,
if you want this thing to flip as
quickly as possible,
basically you want pretty much a lawsuit
to get involved where the dispensary is
shut down and that case has to get up to
the supreme court.
Right?
Like,
is that where you see that ultimately
the only way we're going to stop this
federally is through the Supreme Court?
Right.
I don't know.
I mean,
you know,
I just read something that,
uh,
I think it was normal issued it about
how,
uh,
that's probably not the fastest track,
you know,
it's more of a state's issue and the
more states that,
that,
uh,
legalize it then,
then we'll just kind of give us,
we'll follow.
Hopefully,
you know,
Bernie Sanders said he would schedule
it.
A Hillary Clinton said she'd move it to
schedule to write waffling on this thing
as I mentioned,
but you know what,
for California at least,
I can speak to that a little bit.
I mean,
that's what the La medical cannabis task
force is trying to accomplish here
locally.
You know,
California is like 49 percent of the
national market when it comes to
cannabis and La is,
is the center of all of that for us to
not have common sense regulations for
this industry.
It's ridiculous.
And you know,
we all know it's here,
you know,
the majority of La residents want it
here.
Um,
so how are we going to provide access to
people as part of it that it's hard to
motivate people that smoke pot?
You know what I mean,
like I was trying at the top,
I was trying to say,
you know,
it's hard to,
to have this conversation without saying
things that sound silly like that,
but there's some level of that,
right?
Like,
I can think of my four years of college
when I sat on a couch stone,
but if you had told me,
if I would just go next door,
we could legalize it.
I probably wouldn't have got up.
You know what?
I think it's more fear that,
that has stopped the community from
coming together because when you know
that you could get busted at any time,
it's hard to form alliances,
you know,
it's,
it promotes everyone having a,
you know,
a,
a mentality of being just out for
themselves,
you know,
um,
that's the way it's been.
People operating kind of in the shadows
because I don't want to draw too much
attention to themselves because who
knows what's gonna happen next week,
you know?
Um,
but that's what the task force is trying
to accomplish is,
you know,
the state of California recently passed
some laws that went into effect at the
beginning of this year,
uh,
Murcia medical marijuana regulation and
Safety Act,
uh,
which,
creates a path for legitimacy and,
and licensure for,
for everyone that's in this industry,
but it's up to all the cities,
the cities to,
to then enact regulations that comply
with that.
So La does have an opportunity now and
that's what we're hoping to accomplish
is to,
uh,
get some regulations on the books that
really encourages this industry.
I mean,
we,
we want it here,
you know,
so what should that look like?
What's the,
how do we need to make that happen?
Yeah.
It's so interesting because it's so
much.
Reminds me of the fossil fuel versus
green energy argument because obviously
like the fossil fuel lobbyists,
big pharmacy has a lot of lobbyists,
right?
They're all paying all the politicians
to basically keep weed illegal at some
level,
keep cannabis illegal
because they are trying to sell a lot of
pills.
And it sort of goes back to what you
started with about creating a garden and
a life that you could grow something out
of the earth that could take care of
some of your problems.
And yet we're so afraid of that and we'd
rather them handed to us in pill form.
And then at the same time,
half the commercial for that pill tells
you worse things than you had to take
four in the first place.
Side effects may include doing it.
They should have to show those people
having those side effects,
show someone vomiting and on the toilet
I've been diarrhea and thoughts as soon
as we hang gliding and they're dancing
around and it's like,
come on.
Like how much of that is just related to
politics that the pharmaceutical
companies don't want this to happen.
So
I think that is a big part of it.
I mean,
the way things are a benefits,
a lot of people,
those people don't want to see things
change because that takes money out of
their pockets and it's,
it's pretty simple.
But,
um,
for me,
you know,
it's,
it's not about getting rich for me,
it's about simplifying,
like I said,
and you know,
I would love to just be as self
sufficient as possible.
I mean,
to grow my own food,
to grow my own medicine,
to compost,
to,
you know,
to not have to go to a store for
everything that I need.
I mean that,
that's kind of the default mentality,
you know,
you need something,
you go out and buy it,
you,
you use something,
you're done with it,
you throw it away.
And we're so disconnected from nature,
um,
from what we're doing to the
environment,
you know,
it's so easy to,
to not think about that.
And for me,
um,
cannabis is an important part of taking
care of myself,
you know,
in a way that,
um,
you know,
it,
it helps me in so many ways.
Um,
I don't need to go to a doctor to get
it,
you know.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
when you see those guys,
you know,
if you walk down Venice Boulevard right
on the Strip there and we've got the
guys all dressed in green and there the
four slash 20 doctors,
they got a hat on with a weed leaf and
all that.
Do you think that actually is doing some
of the reverse effect because then
people are like,
this seems so silly.
Yeah,
I think so.
I,
I see a lot of tourists taking pictures
of those a lot.
Um,
I think I did it exactly.
so it's,
it's,
um,
you know,
it's,
it's a spectacle.
I guess that's mostly what they're going
for.
I think I'm down there on Venice beach.
Yeah.
Um,
but I,
I do think it,
it points out kind of the,
the,
uh,
that there isn't really that much of a
difference,
you know,
between,
for,
in my mind,
between medicinal and recreational and
um,
yes,
you have to get a recommendation from a
physician to get it in California.
Um,
yes,
it's pretty easy to do that.
Have there been any.
I mean,
everything that I've read about what's
going on in Colorado right now,
I'd say 90 percent of it has been very
good.
Basically they're bringing in a lot more
tax revenue.
It's,
I don't,
I haven't seen anything about crime
suddenly going up or suddenly other
spikes and other drug use.
You know,
they always say marijuana is a gateway
drug.
What,
what do you say to that?
When people say that
I can't wait.
Uh,
what,
that's what I wonder about,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
okay.
So I've,
I've used cannabis for many years and I
don't like to drink alcohol.
I can occasionally,
but it makes me a sneeze now I get
really congested and I don't,
I just don't really enjoy it.
Um,
so,
and,
and you know,
I think there's been research that shows
that,
you know,
a lot of people that can use drugs and
not get addicted,
you know,
addiction is a,
is a problem.
But to say that just because I smoke
cannabis,
I'm,
you know,
headed down this road where there's,
I'll never come back.
It's,
it's silly.
Well,
I always,
I remember thinking how crazy it was,
the way they've demonized weed because
when I said at the top of the show,
I had never smoked weed until I was a
sophomore in college.
I remember smoking weed and then
laughing or whatever,
whatever went on.
And I remember thinking,
well,
wait a minute,
they've told me weed is so horrible.
So what about these other drugs?
So in a weird way,
by demonizing weed or marijuana and
cannabis,
whatever we're calling it now,
uh,
they actually have convinced a lot of
people I think to try other drugs
because then you try weed,
you go,
this isn't so bad.
Well,
what about crack and crack?
But I'm just saying.
Yeah,
no,
I understand.
Yeah.
Because it's so clearly a
misinformation,
you know,
and people aren't stupid,
you know.
So,
um,
yeah,
I,
it does send the wrong message.
What
do you think about how I noticed that a
lot of my friends who used to be huge,
huge potheads either don't smoke anymore
or barely ever smoke or when they do,
they only need the tiniest flub.
As I said at the top,
I,
I spoke at this point maybe once a
month,
I take one puff,
a granddaddy purple,
the Grand Daddy,
which is an indycar because I told the
guy I just want to melt into the couch
and watch tv and that's it.
And I really,
it's once a month,
one pup,
I'm good to go.
But something about weed is different
than other drugs because people that use
it a lot of seem to.
I think George Carlin did a bit about
this.
They seem to not grow out of it
necessarily,
but it has a reverse addictive thing in
some ways.
You know what I mean?
Some people,
because for the people that get
paranoid,
let's say,
well,
I don't want that anymore.
And I think you would probably say,
well,
that may be trying to go more than a
sativa.
Right?
But what's interesting is,
okay,
so they have found that your body has an
endoccanabinoid system,
right?
So there are receptors in your brain and
all through your body that are there to
accept canabinoids.
Um,
you're,
you,
you produce cannabinoids in your own
body.
You know,
it's in breast milk,
so,
um,
they've found that what cannabis does,
it's just,
it affects your endocannabinoid system
which then brings your body into balance
and that's why it helps with so many
elements and that's why for many years
people couldn't believe that it helps
with so many things.
How could it do this and this and this
and this.
No,
no drug does that.
It's because you have this built in
regulation system in the endocannabinoid
system and cannabis helps bring.
You're bringing that into balance.
So it Kinda does make sense that if
you're using it,
you know,
and that after a certain amount of time,
maybe he need to use less because it's
just such an interesting
thing.
Thing about a drug,
right?
That you know,
you think,
oh,
you need more,
you do it more,
you're going to need more.
And in a lot of ways I know that that
exists at some level with marijuana that
some of my friends,
you know,
they need to smoke more because it
doesn't hit them the way it used to or
they'll change strain or something like
that.
A lot of people eventually either need
much less or have much less of a desire
that,
that doesn't fit any of the definitions
of what addiction and drug.
Exactly.
You just need to.
Normally with addiction you have to keep
upping the dosage and the dosage and you
know,
like for when I use,
when I have an edible cookie at night,
I mean it's 12,
13 milligrams and that's plenty for me.
Yeah.
And I
may not be migraine related.
That might just be
just to,
as a sleep aid,
you know,
or if I'm feeling like it helps if your
muscles are sore,
you know,
just relaxes you.
But 12 milligrams is not a lot.
And um,
and if,
if it were,
you know,
if that were true,
addiction and,
and having to have more and more.
I mean I would be eating more,
more cookies,
you know,
and it's one is fine
right now.
These are all carb free,
right?
Yeah.
So with some of the medicinal stuff,
when I was doing a little research for
this,
you can see all kinds of crazy things.
I mean,
you can see people that say literally,
I cured brain cancer with just by,
you know,
using cbd oil or something like that,
and then you can see people that it
helped with pain or it helped with
nausea.
I got my appetite back.
I mean really the gamut of everything.
What's like the most amazing case that
you've ever seen of,
of helping,
you know,
something really serious like cancer or
Parkinson's or somebody.
Well,
I have a good friend that had kronos,
has crohn's disease and,
you know,
he really credits cannabis with giving
him his life back and he was suffering
tremendously for many,
many years.
And another friend of mine has a,
uh,
a young niece,
um,
who had a brain tumor and she,
her family was treating it with the Rick
Simpson oil.
And um,
what's that?
Um,
it's uh,
it's,
I've never tried it myself,
but it's,
it's,
um,
it's.
Rick Simpson developed this method of
making this concentrated oil.
Um,
and you can find directions on how to
make it yourself.
Was this like what they give very young
kids?
Right.
Does this sound to do with what happened
in New Jersey?
And Kristy got in all that because I
think he didn't want to pass it,
but then got sort of into it,
which made no sense anyway.
I think,
wasn't he just allowing the CBD stuff?
Right.
All right.
So we'll,
we'll try that again.
You don't have to know everything.
Yeah,
I try.
But I think that,
um,
uh,
you know,
I've seen a lot of people who really
believe that it's helped them for so
many different things.
Um,
even if it's just,
you know,
I have a bad back and I rub a topical on
my,
on my back and I feel better.
Um,
it's not always about getting stoned.
So,
um,
you know,
and,
and for a while I was volunteering in a
cannabis physicians office and,
you know,
different.
I would see different patients and how
they were using the medicine.
I mean,
it's,
it's great for any kind of.
I'm a neuro neuro,
uh,
neuropathy,
you know,
any kind of nerve pain.
It,
it,
it's,
uh,
provides great relief for that.
And,
you know,
breast cancer,
there has been studies showing that,
I mean,
they've shown that it can really just
kill certain cancer cells.
I mean,
to me that's incredible.
So for the people that would say this
is,
they still have this stigma attached to
it,
you know,
I think a lot of them,
they don't want people to even deal with
their own pain.
It's unfathomable to me that if someone
across from me had cancer or had
Parkinson's,
the rite eight or whatever it is,
what right would I have to say?
Well,
you can't do that to yourself to
alleviate your pain.
Right.
What do you think goes on in the mind of
that person?
I,
I really,
I cannot imagine.
I,
again,
I think it's fear and misinformation and
that's why.
Thank you so much again for having me
here because think it's,
it's,
it's so important to come out and speak
on the topic.
Uh,
I know I'm fighting a stereotype,
you know,
um,
but I do not consider myself a stoner
and I am very productive,
you know?
So,
uh,
I think that's
the board.
There's money to be made here for a lot
of people.
It's happening in Colorado right now.
It's happening across California.
So this is,
these are serious business people,
right?
It's like the new California gold rush
in a way where you have to be willing to
sort of put your butt on the line,
I suppose for hopefully not
too much longer.
I mean,
we'll see.
We'll see.
I mean,
I think that the energy is definitely
going in the right direction and
hopefully we'll get some regulations in
place,
especially here in la because,
you know,
we,
we are the center of this industry and
we should take a leadership role in
creating regulations that could be used
other places as well.
Um,
and what I'd really like to see is,
uh,
an industry that encourages
entrepreneurship,
encourages a small business owners and
encourages creativity,
uh,
and not a monopoly.
And that's really another,
a goal of the task force is to allow
that to happen.
You know,
really bring everyone in out of the
shadows and operate a legitimately.
Yeah.
So I know you don't buy the gateway drug
thing.
Where do you stand on legalization of
all drugs in general?
Because I think this is probably one of
the places where the argument gets tough
where suddenly you say,
I'm all in on weed and then there's
probably a lot of people that say,
well,
I'm just all in on everything and then
you could get what I would think,
even though I'm basically for
legalization of most stuff,
pretty much I think people could make a
more sound case and say if you legalize
all of this stuff,
people are going to just be trying all
kinds of really crazy.
Okay,
now I'm not,
I'm still sort of vacillating where I
stand.
Okay.
Drugs,
there are many drugs that aren't legal
now that people try and it doesn't limit
people's ability to access,
right?
They can get
right.
Um,
you're risking a going to prison,
you know.
Um,
so I mean,
legalizing all drugs,
I do believe that there are drugs that
don't have any real health benefit and
are dangerous.
Um,
but I don't think criminalizing activity
that way.
Um,
is,
is the right answer.
You know,
if you're trying to fight addiction,
putting someone in prison is not going
to solve that.
I'm preventing them from having a,
a life is not going to solve that.
It's a crazy system that someone could
try to alleviate their pain because of a
chronic disease.
And our,
our,
uh,
the way we deal with them is by putting
them in jail.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
veteran veterans right now I really
fighting to get access to medical
marijuana.
I mean the fact that um,
they've had to fight to be able to treat
their ptsd with cannabis is crazy,
you know,
I mean,
I think they've earned that.
Yeah,
I agree.
All right,
well we have to wrap up.
So first off,
I'm very happy about this.
This is very exciting.
Uh,
I think I've got it already,
but give me your.
Give me your file sale.
Give me your 62nd sell on why all this
is important for our.
So we can clip it for facebook
perfectly.
Why is making this legal and do it all
this?
Just give me,
give me the elevator.
Cannabis medicine is,
you know,
cannabis is an amazing plant.
It has so many health benefits.
It has saved many lives,
um,
to,
to make it illegal or to continue to
keep it illegal.
It just hurts.
It hurts us as a society.
It hurts individuals.
I mean,
it's just bad all around.
this is,
um,
you know,
for me it's about really getting people
to understand that I'm,
I'm,
I'm not a bad person.
You know,
I'm,
I'm here to provide a product that
people enjoy and that people benefit
from.
And um,
you know,
it's time to,
for La especially to,
to,
uh,
accept this industry and to create some
framework for us to,
to,
uh,
to be successful.
Yeah.
I think you nailed it.
Well,
as I told you before we started,
you know,
I spent a lot of time here talking about
terrorism and politics and jihadism in
all kinds of crazy stuff.
So this was an absolute pleasure and
this will help me relaxing after the
show.
So I thank you for that.
And you guys can follow along with
angels doing a.
it's Ruby Doobie,
bakes.com,
right.
And she just signed up for twitter.
So give her a father at Ruby,
ruby based and it's also at Ruby Ruby
lakes on instagram.
How is that?
Pimping is.
That's pretty good.
All right,
thanks for watching and we'll do it
again next week.
Catch new episodes of the Rubin report
each week on Ora.tv,
youtube,
and now featured on the aura tv channel
on your Roku player.